more details tonight about zero
experience hunter biden's memoir where
hunter actually admits that
he wouldn't repeat his work with the
corrupt ukrainian energy company barisma
holdings although he maintains quote i
did
nothing unethical really hunter taking
what five figures a month
profiting off your father's diplomacy
despite having
no experience in ukraine oil gas or
energy
and your father caught on tape bragging
about getting the prosecutor fired that
was investigating you
and barisma you did nothing wrong really
what about the work in china where you
rode on air force two and walked away
with
what went 1.5 billion dollars in a deal
with the bank of china
or the three and a half million dollar
payment to your company
from the former first lady of moscow you
know the russian oligarch
you said that you hated so much or the
money you got from the kazakh
oligarch uh and like the deranged any
deranged
democrat hunter he couldn't write a book
without going after donald trump
calling him a vile man with a vile
mission and of course
what hunter really means is that donald
trump dared to call out the biden's
family foreign crime
syndicate and the corruption and the pay
to play
inside the democratic establishment
remember the biden family sold
out to america's adversaries like china
and hunter
doesn't mention any of that in the book
by the way
what about the hard drive from hell you
know
the hard drive the laptop the democrats
and disgraced former intel officials
falsely claiming you know it was russian
disinformation
is there a chapter on that don't count
on it and hunter if you're so innocent
how about you approve the release of
everything else on the laptop
the pictures hunter the videos hunter
i assume you remember i assume you're
pretty worried about it
and also in the book hunter details his
long history with crack addiction
at one point i dropped clean off the
grid living in a 59
a night super 8 motel off i-95 while
scaring my family
even more than myself here with reaction
radio talk show host dana lash along
with former white house chief of staff
reince priebus
i actually been briefed on the rest of
what's
on this laptop and i'm having a hard
time
knowing what's i've been told by
credible people
is there that this has not come out yet
and that there hasn't been more urgency
on
on the part of law enforcement have you
been briefed on this
uh no but it all comes down to a little
bit of what you talked about in the last
segment too
with this book the media is going to
have an invitation
and the invitation is going to be you're
going to get to ask him when he does
this media tour over this book which is
apparently
a two million dollar deal the media is
going to have a chance to ask him about
china
about burisma about the ukraine people
don't have a problem
i don't think with folks making money
but financially toxic
people they do and people a
reincarnation
he's not if he's not going to do my show
or dana's show i can promise you that
right well you're right but you know can
you imagine i thought i thought about
the millions of dollars that many of us
spent
including eric and don jr in
legal fees defending themselves against
accusations in the mueller investigation
that never even took place let alone
this guy
who did all of these things now it's
writing a book obviously taking his pot
shots at the president
and i think you know that people who
stand
on moral authority should be very
careful what stones they're willing to
throw
and you know it sounds like a lot of
this book is right out of a jerry
springer show so he shouldn't be the guy
throwing stones at anybody dana i don't
know if you
i've talked to people that have seen the
laptop i think you are pretty well aware
and versed on what's in there as well
why has that not come out
that's a great question million dollar
question i mean also why
have say gun control groups not said
anything about all of the
felonies that were committed in the one
story involving him and the gun that was
dumped by his
sister-girlfriend-in-law gourmet grocers
across
from the high school i mean i don't
think that this book anybody nobody
would be interested in this book sean
if he hadn't mentioned trump i i almost
think he he had to add it
you know go in and add it at the last
minute because the editor was like
nobody's going to buy this unless you
mention
trump nobody cares that you paint with
your mouth okay nobody cares
that you're an addict nobody cares about
any of this you haven't really done a
lot on your own in life
say something about trump because it's
the only way you're gonna get pressed i
honestly think that's why he put it in
there
and and you're right he is just opening
the door to the press
now it's fair game because sean they've
been saying media democrats have been
saying this whole time well
you can't bring up hunter biden joe
biden's child this guy's 50 something
years old at some point he's not
somebody's child anymore
he's a grown man with his own children
so yeah he opened the door up on this
one
i i don't even think i could write a a
fiction novel that could
meet the equivalence of him and his
personal life in this
and and the way he's trying to explain
some of the
things that the decisions and the
lifestyle he's chosen
um away reince
well and it's just a wild stuff i mean
this relationship with his sister-in-law
and begging his father
for this statement claiming that this
relationship between
him and his former i mean his brother
who passed away his
wife i mean again i mean the idea as
dana said of
members of powerful political families
making obscene amount of money
that they'd otherwise never be able to
make
on their own let alone writing this sort
of
really sad and unfortunate tell-all book
to make even
more money at a time
i don't know if it's sad or violent it's
like tiger king
2.0 he's the new tiger king
dana if the last name's trump what's the
reaction to this life
moscow china uh ukraine kazakhstan oh
yeah it's a huge double standard like i
said if they turn hunter biden's life in
a netflix series
it's the new tiger king well by the way
the point about lying on the gun
application if you did a dana
i did it reince would get away free he'd
get away scot-free we'd get we'd be in
the pokey we'd be in the jail i think
they put brian's in jail
redemption uh thank you both shawshank
great movie well